were there any people in your indictment
that
went went to jail or went to prison with
you like co-defendants or anything yep
how many people
there's five or six so
uh there's a few people my employees the
people that work for me
and you know what that's crazy too
because
even though a couple of them helped
give them information about me
i can't hold it against them they're all
great
people they've always been good to me
they trusted me
you know they trusted that i knew what i
was doing that they wouldn't get in
trouble
they too didn't belong in prison not
they're all great people
you know i met natalie in church
of all of all places uh you know and
and you know who in church uh natalie
zanetti so she's
one of the all she was doing was sending
money so
i would have fake ids made i would give
her the fake ids
she would go and send money through
western union and moneygram using a fake
id you could use it one time
after you use the fake id you got to cut
it up don't use it again
for whatever reason so this is what you
were doing to
stash your money no this is how we were
initially paying
to order the product i mean you you
gotta you gotta oh
you left that out i don't know you're
making fake ids and doing all that oh
yeah so yeah i would have a whole stack
of big ideas like
holy 100 of them same picture different
real life
real information or as real as possible
that's like what matt was doing
i don't know the depth of what matt was
doing but yeah so you know you gotta
you've got to use the system
he was actually uh he was scanning ids
cut and pasting them like the riddler
and scanning them and and like
literally by hand creating these ids
like wow
yeah i guess that's where the art degree
came in yeah that's the fine arts degree
crazy so natalie how she got caught
was she used the same id twice
so there's two different instances i
think she got out of that i just lost
like 15 or 20 000
so i gave her like 20 000 cash and i
said all right use a couple different
ids
and go send money over a couple day
period
using western union and monogram you can
use each id one time
at western union and moneygram after
that cut it up don't use it again
because when you try to use it again
it's gonna throw a red flag
it's like it runs through their system
and they realize that it's not real and
explain to me why you had to use a
different id every time you sent money
to china because
every single financial transaction is
logged
the department of homeland security the
dea they have access to all of that
so if they see that justin smith or
natalie zanetti
is sending millions of dollars through
china
to china they're going to have some
questions
especially when i can't show on paper
that i'm making that kind of money
and you're only supposed to use western
union for what friends and family
transfers
so you know it's very very tricky thing
so what happened was she went in the
store with i think
five grand maybe and used an id that she
had used before
they kept the id alerted the authorities
kept the money
and i guess they she claimed she got
away
she claimed she didn't get detained she
claimed that
you know that everything was just normal
and they let her continue doing whatever
she was doing
but the reality is is she was busted and
she i'm guessing she you know she
flipped
so at that you know we don't want you
all we all we care about is justin
we know he's the one putting you up to
this we know that he's the one you know
he's the one running the operation he's
the one we want so help us get him
you're you're okay right so and then uh
you know that's how it works they scare
the small fish to get to the big fish
and you know it's effective
but at the same time like i i was the
one that made the wrong call
i was the one that sold this to my
friends that sold this to my employees
that convinced these people to trust me
and honestly that makes me sad man like
like looking back
that's one of my biggest regrets is the
fact that i got really good people in a
lot of [ __ ]
yeah and they didn't deserve that but
you know then you make the argument
they're grown adults they made their own
decisions
they knew the risks did they i don't you
know
it's it's it's a tricky thing but i had
a i was talking to a female that was
on the show and she was talking about
her she went to prison for a few years
and she was
saying that just the women run the
prisons because all the
the prison guards are males and they're
most times than not they're kind of like
dweeby
guys you know they're they don't get
like the big burly tough guys to run the
women's
prisons right because they send them to
the men's prisons
they send like the dweeby nerdy kind of
like frail prison guards to the women's
prisons
and it was super easy for them to
manipulate the guards
so like the girls would like tease them
like sexually
or whatever like and they would go for
it and they would totally go for it and
they basically
ran the prisons the prison camps even if
they did get the big burly guys
i mean think about it but they still
could probably do that right the power
of
can i say [ __ ] yeah power of [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's
it's crazy i mean
human nature's human nature it doesn't
matter if you're an inmate or not like
it's still there frank venice actually
met his wife his first federal bid
she was a psychologist at the prison or
a nurse something like
yeah i met her there and he got married
after another thing people love to marry
it's a thing people where people like to
meet and marry people in prison
specifically like killers and stuff
people who kill people
i so after i completed art app at
pensacola i did a near-home transfer my
sister
had my niece abigail and i didn't have a
relationship with her
and i wanted to build a relationship
with my family i hadn't seen my father
now my mother came to see me but my
father's not big on airplanes he's not
big on traveling very old-fashioned
so i wanted to get closer to home the
closest prison next to ashland kentucky
was
big sandy camp now big sandy is a
notorious
usp big sandy's one of the most
notorious federal prisons in the country
helicopters landing all the time people
getting killed
um multiple black hands for very large
gang organizations there black hands
like the
the the shot caller the guy in charge
the el jefe
okay um el chapo yeah so um
you know so it's a notorious prison but
they also have a satellite camp it's
just a pin
and a camp so you got a maximum security
prison and then you got a camp a minimum
security prison now this prison
it's notorious in the everyone knows
about it it's like
heaven if you have to do time in the
feds
you either want to go to big sandy camp
or you want to go to yankton north
dakota
that's everyone knows that so and the
reason is there's no fence
so you're not fenced in there's no lock
doors there's no handcuffs
there's no guards there's nobody
policing you
you can drive vehicles if you have
community custody you can drive in the
community
they'll give you a credit card and let
you go to the store and buy stuff and
bring it back to the prison because
you're trusted to do that
i serviced 40 44 vehicles i was the
clerk at the auto garage
i was also the head chef during
lockdowns so during a lockdown
which was almost all the time because
they can't behave at the penitentiary
they're always trying to kill each other
the they would bring the campers down
there to run the kitchen
and you know it's funny a lot of those
guards there will tell you
the only reason we're in prison is to
help them run the prison
and the these guards they acknowledge i
mean i've heard multiple people
multiple guards tell me like do keep
your head up because you're a good dude
and you're a hard worker and that's all
that really matters
you know you're gonna you're gonna
unfortunately you're gonna experience
some pushback
it's not gonna be as easy for you as it
was before but
your heart's in the right place and
that's really what matters
honestly it it it's just a wild there
wasn't
there was 59 inmates at big sandy when i
got there that's another reason people
want to go there there's no one there no
it's a ghost town yeah and there wasn't
one person at that facility
that you couldn't trust living next to
you they're all they're all good people
they made mistakes they you you can call
them
mistakes like something you did the one
they made the wrong choices
for the wrong reasons sure
you